as hurricane durian lingers dangerously
close to the US East Coast residents of
Charleston are dealing with downed trees
flooding and tropical storm force winds
thousands lost power here tidal surges
remain a danger and more than 300,000
South Carolinians have moved to shelters
but most agree things could have been a
lot worse I'm just used to it I'm
ex-military and this is nothing compared
to combat so you know it's it's it's all
good I'm okay as South Carolina prepares
for a cleanup Dorian is now tracking
towards North Carolina's Outer Banks the
eye of the hurricane may not make
landfall but this will be a close call
for an area already under mandatory
evacuation
this won't be a brush by whether it
comes ashore or not the eye of the storm
will be close enough to cause extensive
damage in North Carolina
tornado is produced by the power of
Dorian have been reported throughout the
region forming and touching down with
little warning for South Carolina though
the storm is passing albeit slowly some
streets here have flooded and trees have
blown down but thankfully the wind
changed direction sparing the city from
those large tidal surges dangers remain
from flash floods and strong gusts of
wind but forecasters are now watching
for that long predicted east and turn of
hurricane Dorian and that for North
Carolina will be vital residents and
emergency staff in North Carolina are
now bracing for the power of Dorian as
it creeps northwards this may be the
closest yet that Dorian has come to the
US coast and the dangers are still
life-threatening stay informed know your
zone if your zone is an evacuation zone
get out there's no reason to stay behind
and become a statistic or become a
problem for first responders to have to
deal with as hurricane Dorian continues
it's slow path hurricane and tropical
storm warnings remain in place the
system is so big there are watches in
place as far north as Massachusetts but
for now it's North Carolina that remains
in Dorian's path and the gallic are al
jazeera Charleston South Carolina